[Music]  well back to school is monday and  drivers are reminded to be  careful in school zones as students head  back to class and today  the valley's police department's holding  a pedestrian enforcement exercise  near rancho high school now a lot of  time has passed since kids have been  around school campuses and police say  drivers and pedestrians both have picked  up some bad habits over the last year  so far this year we've had 38 fatalities  for pedestrians so those are just people  who are out you know walking riding  their bikes  so we just really need to remind  everybody to please slow down pay  attention  and to the pedestrians out there also we  always like to stress  use the crosswalks they're here for a  reason  in all today the traffic enforcement  team made 62 stops  issued 60 tickets and then even clocked  one car that was going 67  in a 35.